1.4 miles away from the raiders
intermountain healthcare performance
center is liberty high school the home
of the state champion patriots and
tonight kevin martin she joins us for
the second edition of friday night
showcase series good evening kevin
well good evening john it is
liberty high school versus canyon
springs tonight friday night lights and
it's the raiders showcase game of the
night and i'm joined by former raider
chris macklemore and chris you are a las
vegas native you played high school
football here in valley high what's it
like to be back out here for friday
night lights in las vegas it almost
makes me want to go get on the field
right now
at these guys if the music going in the
background they're probably sitting at
their locker been waiting all summer
working hard this is exciting and i know
it's exciting for them and i know it's
always so important for
current writers and former raiders to
give back just sitting here and watching
fans come up with the biggest smile and
getting to meet you and get your
autograph and we were speaking a little
bit off camera about another initiative
that the raiders did they actually gave
helmets out to canyon springs who's
playing here tonight and then also your
your alma mater valley high what does
that mean to you and so much that the
raiders keep giving back you know i just
i'm a part of the community i'm a part
of this opportunity as a young man when
i was playing at valley high school we
did not have something like this so this
is exciting knowing that not only did we
give hamlets to my armada valley school
i mean probably high school vikings but
we're in the community giving back to
the community and being a part of an
exciting time
it's friday night football the lights
are beaming we're getting ready to play
high school football again and you know
what we went through last year we didn't
have this opportunity now we're back
we've mingling kids are fired up we're
excited thank you so much chris for your
time and of course we'll have highlights
from this huge matchup between liberty
and camden springs coming up at 11
reporting live at liberty high school
kevin martin 8 sports now